Dr Chapman Dear John
your Royal highnesses your highness
excellencies distinguished guests ladies
and gentlemen
allow me first of all to thank the
double I double s
for its continued leadership and
inconvening a regional dialogue
and it's a pleasure and an honor to be
back here in Manama in Bahrain
it is so good to see that Bahrain
continues to be a driving force for
dialogue between countries and cultures
and indeed since my last visit four
years ago
behind's achievements have been
remarkable
in difficult times for the world you
have been a voice of wisdom and a voice
for engagement and we wholeheartedly
thank you for that
[Applause]
I have come to Bahrain I've come to the
gulf directly from the G20 Summit in
Bali
this was the first G20 Summit since
Russia invaded Ukraine and of course the
summit was dominated
by the spillover effects of this
atrocious War
take for example food security
the Russian blockade of Ukraine's port
the deliberate bombing
of grain sealers
the disruption of Ukraine agriculture
all that
is having devastating effects on Global
Food security
and therefore we welcome yesterday's
prolongation of the Black Sea grain deal
for 120 days
however given the uncertainties
we have to boost even more our
alternative routes
this is why the European Union just
invested an additional billion euros
into linking Ukraine's granaries
to our courts by Railroad and rivers
we call them solidarity Lanes these
solidarity Lanes have
since the beginning of the war
taken more than 60 percent of Ukrainian
food exports to the rest of the world
this is more than 17 million tons
altogether
the second big topic was of course
energy security
in energy no one knows better than you
in the Gulf
that it is all about trust
and reliability
and for many years you have supplied
energy to the world
to support its economic and social
development
this has been transformative for many
many lives and livelihoods
we are now in the middle of a difficult
and turbulent period of History
tectonic shifts in the energy landscape
are happening right now
Before the War started
Europe was Russia's biggest Energy
customer
today
not even nine months later
this has changed fundamentally
Russia has unilaterally
and deliberately
cut 80 percent of its pipeline gas to
Europe but
Europe has managed to replace most of
this gas
from reliable suppliers
our storages are full at 95 percent
and we are safe for this winter
our challenge will be next year's winter
but at the same time
for emerging and developing countries
the energy crunch is happening right now
they are facing skyrocketing energy
expenditures
soaring inflation
and the energy crisis is rapidly leading
into an unsustainable debt crisis
therefore the world is looking to the
Key Energy suppliers
to ensure that these countries
that rely on imported fuels and are
vulnerables
have access to gas and oil at reasonable
prices
so much for the immediate crisis but let
me tell you the tectonic shifts are
going much much deeper
it is climate change that is the
pacemaker
you know it all desertification is
rapidly swallowing fertile land
devastating floods covered one-third of
Pakistan this summer
forest fires raged across Europe even in
Belgium and the United Kingdom
and there is a reason why the largest
economies of the world
3020 reaffirmed the Paris climate goals
the clean energy transformation will
take place
and the winners
will be those
we invest now
and who invest massively
in clean tech and in necessary
infrastructure
Europe is investing massively into
homegrown renewable energy
this is our so-called European green
deal our growth strategy
but in addition
we will also continue to rely on energy
Imports
and many of the countries of this region
have the natural resources for clean
energy in abundance
the wind the sun you name it
and you have the know-how on existing
and emerging Technologies such as carbon
capture and Storage
this defining change is creating vast
opportunities
for today's Major Energies exporters
to provide the fuels and the Energy
Services of tomorrow
to diversify into low emission fuels
such as hydrogen
to show leadership in areas such as CC
us
and as a result
of these changes
to diversify also their broader
economies
and to provide a sustainable basis for
long-term growth
of course
what is behind
this crisis
food security
and an energy security
is Russia's War
and let me give you a European
perspective of what of what's happening
on European soil
and the global implications
almost nine months ago
Russian tanks rolled across an
internationally recognized border
with a declared objective
to bring down a legitimate government
and establish
rule from Moscow
but Russia's efforts have backfired
spectacularly
it has proven to be a colossal strategic
mistake
first of all
the people of Ukraine have fought
bravely with grit and determination to
defend their own freedom
to reaffirm their independence
and their right
to determine their own future
if Putin was aiming to wipe Ukraine off
the map
he achieved the exact opposite
the nation of Ukraine stands today
stronger than ever
secondly
if Putin wanted to divide Europe and its
partners and allies
he failed yet again
Sweden and Finland will join NATO
Denmark has removed its defense opt-out
and Ukraine is now a candidate to join
the European Union
and thirdly this war is weakening
Russia's economic perspective for
decades to come
our technology sanctions are crippling
Russia's economy for the future
and its Industries and tatters
from an energy point of view
Russia has lost its biggest customer
Europe is ending its dependency on
Russian fossil fuels for good
from a military point of view
the Russian army has shown its
weaknesses and appears overstretched
its military industrial complex is
lacking chips
and spare parts
to fix the hardware
the equipment that Russia is throwing at
the front line
is getting older and older
the conscripts
who arrive with it
are barely trained
and younger and younger
and from a diplomatic point of view
Russia's illegal annexation of four
Ukrainian regions
has been roundly rejected as a sham
around the world
it was condemned by 143 countries in the
UN General Assembly including by the
overwhelming majority of the Gulf
the Middle East
and North Africa
in some
has achieved a weaker Russia
domestically and abroad
the European Union is United
and steadfast in its support to Ukraine
as long as it takes
from the very beginning we have provided
a strategic answer
with massive and tailored sanctions with
broad humanitarian Aid with substantial
financial support of over 20 billion
euros
and for the first time ever
the European Union directly financed
military assistance of over 3.1 billion
euros
ladies and gentlemen
my last point is about the international
order and how to defend it
there is one recent development that I
find very telling
last January
exactly one month before Russia attacked
Ukraine
civilians in Abu Dhabi
came under Fire
of Iran made Shahid 136 uavs launched
from Yemen
just a few days ago the oil tanker
Pacific Circle
was attacked off the coast of Oman by
the very same Iranian drones
and now in Europe too
Russia has launched these very same
Iranian drones
time and again against civilian Targets
in Ukraine's cities
these are blatant breaches of
humanitarian law
and qualify as War crane crimes
several Gulf countries have been warning
for years about the risk
that Iran feeds Rogue Nations around the
world with strongs
it took us too long to understand a very
simple fact
[Applause]
the very simple fact that why we work to
prevent Iran from developing nuclear
weapons
we must also focus on other forms of
weapons proliferations from drones to
ballistic missiles
it is a security risk not just for the
Middle East but for all of us
and this is why the European Union has
already sanctioned Iranian individuals
and entities linked to the Iranian
revolutionary guards that are
responsible for providing drones to
Russia
and we are coordinating with partners
and allies to take further sanctions
against Iran responding to the
proliferation of Iranian drones
by teaming up Iran and Russia
undermining the basic rules and
principles of our Global Order
and where does this end if left
unchallenged
history shows that this is a recipe for
Perpetual War
it is a recipe
for arms racists and the proliferation
of weapons of mass destruction
it is a recipe for constant foreign
interference for never-ending violence
and instability
and we simply cannot accept this and we
will not accept this
ladies and gentlemen
the world needs a stronger security
architecture against this spread of
Chaos
we know this in Europe
and it matches also here in the Gulf
Europe is willing to do its part
we want to strengthen our engagement
with the region
both economically but also in terms of
security
we want closer cooperation on Maritime
security for instance
to ensure safe shipping lanes
and I am also convinced that we should
work on a coordinated approach to Iran
with a broader Focus than nuclear
Gulf security matters to Europe
as Europe's security matters to the Gulf
therefore we in the European Union will
appoint a special representative to the
Gulf
so let us join forces for our collective
security
ladies and gentlemen
I believe we Face historic opportunities
historic opportunity to build new ties
between our regions for our mutual
interest and benefit
for today
and for the long run
thank you very much for hosting me and
I'm looking forward to the discussion
thank you very much
[Applause]